hi in this video we would look at how
pregnancy tests to work at the end of
this video you would appreciate that how
the basic principles of antigen-antibody
interaction is used to test pregnancy so
you are familiar with the pregnancy
strip and if you see two bands in the
pregnancy strip you might think okay
that you're pregnant right how does that
work so here you put your drop of urine
and then let the urine flow by capillary
action and there are specific zones
where you see the band and based on
number of bands you think you're
pregnant or not pregnant so how does
that really work at molecular level so
this is the focus of today's topic
looking at the particular pregnancy
strip we would see there is a reaction
zone there is a catch zone and there is
a control zone and in a little bit time
we would understand the details of all
of these before that let's try to
understand the basic principle this is
the genitalia of a particular woman you
see the ovary here and the uterine wall
so let's say this woman is pregnant so
there would be implantation right now
inside the when the embryo is implanted
there is some hormone which is secreted
known as human chorionic gonadotropin
human chorionic gonadotropin is helped
to maintain the uterine wall and it is
secreted by the early placenta so human
chorionic gonadotropin actually promotes
and maintain maintain and help in
maintenance of the corpus luteum now
corpus luteum is the source of
progesterone right human chorionic
gonadotropin bind to the receptor on
corpus luteum and stimulate it to secret
progesterone reinforcing the level of
progesterone ensures that the uterine
wall does not collapse during pregnancy
and really
become thick and rich in blood vessels
which would really help to not share the
embryo throughout these nine months so
this is the basic take home for this
video that a pregnant woman should have
human chorionic gonadotropin and a woman
who is not pregnant she should not have
the human chorionic gonadotropin in her
urine right so the presence of human
chorionic gonadotropin is somehow going
to be detected using an antibody antigen
interaction based method so let's look
at it how does it happen so here is your
reaction zone where you put your urine
sample as the urine sample flows by
capillary action what happens is your
antibodies also flow provided this urine
sample has some human chorionic
gonadotropin which is depicted here as
the red blobs they would detect it and
they would migrate towards the test site
or the test zone right and as they
migrate towards the test zone in the
test zone there are specific antibodies
already present these antibodies which
are present in the test zone can also
detect human chorionic gonadotropin but
they detect a different epitope so once
these HCG aunty so first of all there
are HCG antibodies and some dye
molecules which can be cleaved by
specific enzymes now once our antibody
which was present in the reaction zone
flows with the flow of the urine to this
particular region in this particular
case they would be binding to the nth CG
antibody present in this region because
there has the HCG present and that means
there would be a enzyme substrate
reaction because these blue antibodies
that means the anti hcg antibodies which
are present in the reaction zone they
have the enzyme associated with them
which can cleave these livable dye and
give a red coloration so this red
coloration appears as a band
in the strip okay now we understand one
band what happens to us to the second
man so let's look at it now as the urine
flows some amount of antibodies is
always unbound and that would be flowing
to the next zone which is the control
zone in the control zone you have some
antibody which is against Mouse FC
region now provided your antibody which
was against human chorionic gonadotropin
was raised in Mouse its FC region is
actually detected by this anti Mouse
antibody and regardless you have gone
under dropping bind to these antibodies
or not bound to these antibodies doesn't
matter
this enzyme would come to a contact with
these substrates and would cleave the
substrates forming a red band again
regardless of HCG present in the urine
sample or others not present this
particular band in the control zone
would always be seen if this band is not
seen that means somehow this antibodies
are not working or somehow these
antibodies has been degraded so the
control band is very important to
understand whether the pregnancy test is
successful or not so now we clearly
understand if you have two bands that
means it's positive if you have only the
control band no test band that means
it's a negative test but if you have no
control band noticed band or let's say
you have a test band but no control band
that means that particular test
something has gone wrong and it's
considered as invalid you have to do the
test again so after that you would
really understand why two bands means
positive test for pregnancy and that's
why this woman is pretty much excited
for her it's a wonderful experience now
she should not be that excited and
definitely should visit the doctor to
consult him because in case of many
cancers such as cervical cancers uterine
cancers human chorionic gonadotropin can
also be found in the urine
so if there is no adequate reason for
pregnancy so this is a thing
to think about so with that we pretty
much covered how pregnancy tests take
place and what are the basis at the
level of antigen antibody interaction
we also looked at how the test is mostly
accurate but sometimes it can give false
positive result in case of some cancers
or some kind of pathology associated
situations so I hope you enjoyed this
video if you like this video give it a
big thumbs up don't forget to Like share
and subscribe thank you and do let me
know in the comments how you like my
videos and your comment give me so much
motivation to make more such animations
and these videos signing off thank you